there's a big media campaign now to say
that Russell Brand is a rapist there was
an accusation made wasn't made in a
court primarily it wasn't made through a
prosecutor's office primarily it was
made in newspapers
from multiple women who say back in the
day Russell Brandt raped me or he was
otherwise abusive or he's a no down
dirty rotten guy I read the report it
came from the times and in it the women
say I I didn't want to speak out until I
was approached by journalists and then I
decided to tell my story so this really
is a media created thing my big takeaway
is Russell Brand guilty or not I don't
know I'm all for tightening up
lewdness laws and obscenity laws
everything we were talking about at the
top of the show I'm all for that you
can't do that retroactively you you
can't have a culture and a law that says
hey do whatever you want with all sorts
of weird sex stuff and then later on
comes back and says oh actually that was
bad so we're going to change the law 20
years later and throw you into prison